[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance behind the underhanded deceit
of the Jared Kushner secret Russian
communications scandal and its
implications for Donald Trump's
incumbency there is a possibility that
could be more dire still for Trump there
is reason to believe that the former
national security adviser Lieutenant
General Michael Flynn has already
flipped has already begun to offer
testimony against the Trump regime to
the authorities and that the present
flood of Kushner story's main lines
directly back to Flynn and that the
Kushner crises may in effect be Flynn's
samples it is speculative at best but if
Flynn is already talking and if Flint
has already given the Justice Department
Kushner he may very well be negotiating
right now for full or fuller immunity in
exchange for his evidence about their
other targets in the Trump Russia
investigation and flatly there are not
many they would need Flynn for besides
Trump himself or it could easily be that
Flynn made a deal to nail Kushner and
the hope is that Kushner will break and
give up Trump it is speculative but two
of the smartest people I have ever
interviewed are doing some of this
speculating senator Sheldon Whitehouse
of Rhode Island on CNN quote there is at
least a reasonable hypothesis that Mike
Flynn is already cooperating with the
Department of Justice investigation and
perhaps even has been for some time and
if that's the case then having
congressional committees drag him in
front of Congress could be a significant
interference that could also be why
Flynn had his attorney Robert Keller
invoked the Fifth Amendment for him when
the Senate Intelligence Committee
demanded documents from them may Flynn
has a deal with the Justice Department
or as close to one and he does not have
a deal with the Senate committee why on
earth would he cooperate with the
committee
this same bell rang with another one of
the smartest people I have ever
interviewed the national security
analyst juliek I am it was a
ding-ding-ding cuz all of a sudden
things started to make sense it explains
why Flynn's lawyers are not being
cooperative with the Senate and House it
may also explain why we're starting to
hear stories about the Kushner Flynn
relationship she added I'm just putting
the pieces together here I would not be
shocked to learn that Flynn
trying to get a deal with the FBI it
should be noted here that Juliet Khayyam
in early March looked at the flurry of
talk about testimony from and subpoenas
to all the principal's in the Trump
Russian Nexus and said in effect hold on
how come there's nothing here about Mike
Flynn maybe he's negotiating a deal
within days of her inference and she was
slammed left and right for her inference
Flynn's lawyer the one with the degree
in Russian Studies who wrote his thesis
about Trotsky and was one of the last
Republican never Trump errs standing
within days Flynn's lawyer publicly
offered to have his client testify but
only with significant immunity and oh by
the way Juliet Khayyam was proved only
entirely right there is also something
to be gleaned I think from a little
forensic reverse engineering about the
Jared Kushner Russian spy hotline story
but blew another hole in the Trump
regime when the Washington Post printed
it in the opening paragraph we learned
the story of Kushner's meeting with the
Ambassador Sergei kis back that it's
sourced quote according to US officials
briefed on intelligence reports in the
second paragraph we read something more
specific Kushner's pitch to the russian
ambassador at trump tower is known quote
according to intercepts of russian
communications that were reviewed by US
officials and before trump could scream
that that meant his phones were tapped
there's this quote neither the meeting
nor the communications of Americans
involved were under US surveillance
officials said so Russian communications
were intercepted but we were not
surveilling the meeting nor the
Americans that were in that meeting that
may mean these intercepts of Russian
communications were done by some other
country's intelligence officials all the
American intelligence community may have
is somebody else's tapes or transcripts
plus the three central points of the
theory of the Trump Russia case our
money registration role hacking to
facilitate micro targeting voters in
swing states and disinformation what if
this wild story
the president's son-in-law thought
talking directly to the Kremlin via
Russian spy facilities was a
good idea what if this is actually just
another plant just more disinformation
designed to destabilize the country's
politics the post even anticipated us
there Russia at times feeds false
information into communication streams
it suspects are monitored as a way of
sowing misinformation and confusion
among US analysts but officials said
that it's unclear what kiss lack would
have had to gain by falsely
characterizing his contacts with Kushner
to Moscow great but if the prospect of
disinformation had already occurred to
the reporters and their sources and the
US intelligence community and if our
intelligence community was not
eavesdropping on this conversation and
all we have is some other country's
intelligence product why are they so
certain that this remarkable damning
story about Kushner unfolded just as
ambassador kis lyac said it did when he
told his masters in Moscow
what is the intelligence community's
second source confirming all this to say
nothing of the Washington Post second
source confirming all this what sold
them what convinced them well I skipped
something in paragraph number three
didn't I quote the meeting was also
attended by Michael Flynn Trump's first
national security adviser if US
intelligence or the Justice Department
were both ran some other countries
kushnir kis lacked transcript past flynn
and he had a deal with them or even the
outline of a deal with them all he would
have had to have said to convince the
agencies that that's the way it happened
would have been one word yes indeed it
is all speculative at best but the Trump
Russia scandal has continued to drip day
by day and week by week since last
autumn in an operational sense the only
real change in the entire process
occurred in March when we stopped
hearing almost anything about and
certainly hearing anything from Michael
Flynn if he is talking if the Kushner
story was a sample if he's the
verification of the kiss Lee act
transcript Donald Trump is running out
of time resist
peace